100 складових з дерева і картону.
Завдання - збудувати власне поселення.
Ян Кронауер та Йоганнес Йеґер грають у настільну гру,
а потім пояснюють правила і стратегії на своєму каналі в YouTube.
Вони займаються цим вже чотири роки.
Я просто хотів грати більше. Так ми й почали.
Адже якщо ми рецензуємо ігри, то змушені грати більше.
Спершу виникла ідея ігрового вечора, а потім вже -
робити рецензії на настільні ігри, що, зрештою, і дає можливість більше грати.
Щодня - нова гра. Виробники надають ігри безкоштовно.
Обидва геймери живуть на кошти від реклами на веб-сайті та спонсорів.
Ми справді граємо від початку і до кінця.
Ідея полягає в тому, що ми не просто граємо,
а й намагаємось показати тим, хто нас дивиться,
що грати в настільні ігри весело.
Адже мені здається, що в багатьох застаріле уявлення про ігри,
бо вони, можливо, грали лише раз у "Скрабл" із бабусею чи в "Монополію".
Індустрія настільних ігор зростає, створюючи так звані "людотеки",
тобто зібрання ігор, де зустрічаються любителі пограти.
70% німців грають у настільні ігри. Відповідно виникають і нові професії,
приміром, автори настільних ігор.
Першу гру Софії Ваґнер саме випустили у продаж.
У ній треба розбудувати торговельні імперії на островах.
Я почала розробляти з чотири десятки ігор.
Деякі припинила доволі швидко. Інші вже фактично готові.
Я зараз пропоную їх видавцям для виробництва і
сподіваюся, що вони захочуть запустити їх на ринок.
Німецькі ігри експортуються по всьому світу.
Подекуди настільні ігри навіть називають "німецькими іграми".
Лише у ФРН 2017 року було продано 40 мільйонів настільних ігор.
Величезний ринок.
Втім, хіба це не парадоксально?
Як можна досягти успіху з настільними іграми в цифрову добу?
Власник цього видавництва ігор мав неабиякі сумніви, розпочинаючи свій бізнес.
В Ессені на ярмарку ігор кількість учасників уперше досягла чотиризначного числа.
Вперше понад 1000 учасників представили понад 1100 нових ігор.
Спершу я думав, що збожеволів, збираючись заснувати ще одне видавництво у цьому потоці,
адже бізнес, імовірно, не протримається на воді.
Ці побоювання були марними. Основні замовники настільних ігор –
платоспроможні люди, яким за 30 і які багато часу сидять за комп'ютером і смартфоном,
тож іноді хочуть чогось справжнього.
Цей канал в YouTube має понад 23 тисячі підписників.
Настільні ігри – недешеві.
Справді, настільні ігри зараз - дороге хобі.
Особливо якість продукції змінилася.
Тож, наприклад, гра з сотнею зомбі, сотнею фігурок зомбі може коштувати 100 євро.
Це гігантська коробка з витратним виробництвом.
Такого раніше не було.
Аби ж додатково збільшити продажі,
багато виробників пропонують свої ігри ще й як додаток для смартфону.